Jim Brooks is here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you Jim I'm good I'm good
how I mean that that seems like you've
downgraded since you heard about Kawhi
Leonard and Paul George coming right
it's still settling in by the way I love
that you name the Joan of Arc of the NBA
that Sterling's mistress there should be
a statue of George yes it does start
right with it be a great statue she's
holding up a recording device I don't
know what staples put put her a statue
of with V stiviano is that a face Divya
would they put right next to Kareem or I
don't know if that fits Jim I don't know
if that fits
but just I want to give you what what
can you believe it I mean give voice to
what clipper fans when it came when it
came over I was I was texting my son
about earthquake preparations and and
and then it came across the screen and I
and everybody was saying the Lakers
everybody was saying it and came across
the screen that Kauai has decided to go
with the Los Angeles and I turned away I
just didn't want to see the Lakers come
up and then and then basketball was
changed it's a good way to put it
basketball was changed I mean cuz how
long have you been a season ticket
holder Jim from the moment they came to
Los Angeles from the grimmest of days
from San Diego and they came up from the
San Diego Shepherd clip I heard that
they were moving and I pulled over and
ordered season ticket no kidding why so
why did you never get into the Lakers
what did that happen because I was into
them at that I just you know it just I
don't know how to explain it for if you
have a certain kind of dark soul the
Lakers aren't for you the glist just
just contrasts with you too much I mean
I'll be honest with you you know Jim I
mean you got a you got an Academy Award
in the trophy case I know that that
happened yet by the time that the
Clippers arrived but you know you'd
never come in from New York City you
never bought into the Lakers in a way
that you bought into the Clippers no no
no and it was perverse and I'm telling
you the years that you went through and
there's absolutely no exaggeration
buddy who you didn't know well you'd get
into a conversation they'd say you talk
sports and they'd say you're are you
Lakers fan and you'd say Clippers and
they've laughed and every time but
they'd laugh and I'd always resent the
laugh and I'd look at them with
resentment and they'd look at me about
what the hell am i resenting and there
were years like that so how what was the
lowest of the low
Jim before we get to the the early days
in the Sports Arena where there were
very few people there and I'm telling
you I'm haunted by the echo of the sound
of the basketball was no crowd there at
all I like you like you were watching a
practice yeah that I think that was
those early days were low the injuries
were terrible so many key injuries I
started to wonder if something was wrong
with the floor I really started to think
there was there was something they
should find and and then and then when
we had a good scene we had a bad locker
room and then and then recently the last
two years have been joyous because of
what they were building no I know
James L Brooks Jim Brooks the Academy
award-winning director producer writer
here on the Rich Eisen show I know so
many clipper fans loved the team last
year because nobody expected it and they
came together and there was so much to
root for and now what does it feel like
to be part of here in Los Angeles
a hot ticket with an owner in a front
office and a coach that knows exactly
what the hell they're doing
Jim a great owner like an amazing front
office that you when you think of the
trades they made when you when you think
of how we recovered from Chris Paul
leaving when when Blake got traded when
you know we were trading our best
players almost seriously when Tobias got
traded and what we got for it and how
they built it it's just you know it's
and and everybody loved the team last
year so you could not love them doc was
I'm sure being absolutely sincere the
most fun he's ever had coaching because
the gritty teamwork chemistry everything
right and now here they are again it's
it's it's really it's amazing how hot a
ticket that they are have you had people
call you up and ask you know to be a
plus-one that you have
heard from yet I'm a long time Jim no no
no no it's but but it's it's going to
happen you know a lot of the Simpson
staff goes I put a share share my seats
with the with the Simpson step so it so
the whole work situation is Clippers
fans well I know you got a table read
coming up I mean for for the latest
Simpsons episode do you expect to get
people coming up to you and saying for
the first time I want to go to a clipper
game I see no no it's been celebratory
we had we're at that show is deep in
Clippers fans and what I'm hoping
happens now because what it was is is
that usually when you go to a clipper
home game a fifth to almost half a crowd
is rooting for the other team and I'm
hoping that no longer happens so can we
go are we gonna get Kawhi on on on The
Simpsons Jim we're gonna get Kawhi on
what do you say no patience you know we
we can kill the reticence rumors all at
one right exactly you put them on The
Simpsons and put put Kawhi with I mean
what would be I mean let's just
spitballing right now what would be just
in your mind the perfect foil for that
would be Homer what would it be
something from Hank Azaria so I I think
we could serve him I think we could
serve him well we've had we've had
players on before and and and we've and
we've had some come by the reads is that
right so who is the best one that you've
had on the one that you thought this guy
or gal has got the best jobs that's been
on The Simpsons you know I mean I think
I think you know everybody ends up
coming through because of the nature of
how we record it right it gets pretty
loose you know III think that's
generally true of our guest stars but
what do you think what do you think this
year of the team because I I can name
like seven teams in the Western Division
where their fans have a right to expect
a good season okay let's go through it
then Jim Jim Brooks here in the Rich
Eisen show I like what Utah's done and I
like what Portland's done nobody's
talking about him because everybody's
talking about what's going on here in
Los Angeles those are the teams I'd be
most concerned about for real and the
Rockets that they were there
run it back and they're the ones that
that won't have to gel and figure out
and walk through I mean the Blazers
essentially added a white side and then
you've got the the Rockets can just but
you haven't run it ever you know and you
Denver can run it back too
I mean it is loaded but the fact that
you as a clipper fan hasn't have a team
that's as good as anybody else and
you've got the most red-hot player with
the culture we hope doesn't change
that's the big thing a gritty hard
fighting physical team and I think I
think will retain that culture for sure
did you see that that Kauai signed for
two years plus one did you see that Jim
option play the option of the third year
correct player off so it's basically
it's a two-year deal or any any any
concern on that front I think this is
this is you know obviously when what the
team gave up and this is very much about
the present this is there is no next
year I mean that's clear isn't it I mean
this this is this is what everything's
been built for the coming seasons yeah
hey before I let you go when you you
mentioned earlier that that you would be
in conversation with people and you
mentioned clipper fans and Laker fans
would laugh at you was was Nicholson
every one of those gym with you you know
you know something he always he was one
of my first phone calls I invited him to
a Clippers Lakers game when it's when
it's Clippers of the home team
yes and he's he's he's always been
gentle with me you know I mean even
those years when his team is just great
he was always he was only sweet he was
always encouraging and this time around
I mean it's it's it's it's great what's
it this is a great year for basketball
coming up I mean I am everybody says the
same thing everybody says I can't wait
that's that's it that's like everybody
you know everybody says anybody but
Trump everybody says I can't believe it
before I let you go it just indulge me
with with your best Andy Kaufman story
that you have from your days maxi just
we're meeting
Andy Kaufman who brought back
professional wrestling I mean he did
single-handedly do it which people might
forget and he went into a wrestling
match and and then he it was it became
front-page and news when he was on taxi
that he that he had been injured and he
was in traction and then I saw the video
and we slowed down the video and it was
obvious that he had almost with a stunt
man's ability that had had been a
fake-face load to him and a fake injury
and I was pissed off and I called I
called him in the hospital we're where
he was where he was carried still
carrying the thing as far as he could
carry it and I said you know you you
know what it's like to really feel that
you've been seriously hurt he says you
know what it's like to be in traction
with your not detraction so you wanted
to fake traction to try and sell what he
was trying he went into real traction
over a fake right when it's a real
traction to try and sell the fact that
he was fake injured yet yeah all right
yeah well Jim when you've got time I'd
love to have you here in studio tell
more stories like that I'd love to just
go down that rabbit hole with you and
congrats on don't get your clippers up
to speed here okay we'll do it you got
here you got it that said James L Brooks
Jim Brooks at Canyon Jim you want to
follow him for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR Live or download
the Rich Eisen show app